Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要每周获取独家加更剧集、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能用一个假名字，你常去的咖啡馆名字，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢什么浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改拿铁的订单是不是太晚了？但如果你拥有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你可以直接在家制作浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. New York City, 1938. In a high-rise art deco apartment, America's most intrepid archaeologist is peering at a mysterious stone tablet found in the mountains north of Ankara. Sandstone, he murmurs. Christian symbol. Early Latin text. Mid-12th century, I should think. And then, almost in disbelief, he begins to translate the inscription. Who drinks the water I shall give him, says the Lord, will have a spring inside him, welling up for eternal life. Let them bring me to your holy mountain in the place where
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。纽约市，1938年。在一间装饰艺术风格的高层公寓里，美国最大胆的考古学家正凝视着一块在安卡拉以北山区发现的神秘石碑。砂岩，他喃喃自语。基督教符号。早期拉丁文文本。公元12世纪中叶，我想是的。接着，他几乎难以置信地开始翻译上面的铭文。主说，谁喝了我所赐的水，他腹中就要涌出泉水，直涌到永生。愿他们带我到你的圣山，到你
you dwell, across the desert and through the mountain, to the canyon of the crescent moon, to the temple where the cup that holds the blood of Jesus Christ resides forever. The Holy Grail, Dr. Jones, says his host. The chalice used by Christ during the Last Supper. The cup that caught his blood at the crucifixion and was entrusted to Joseph of Arimathea. And so, Tom Holland begins our hero's thrilling hunt for the Holy Grail in the film Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade. Now, you love the Holy Grail, Tom, don't you? I hunt for the Holy Grail in the film Indiana Jones and the Last
居住的地方，穿过沙漠，翻越群山，来到新月之月峡谷，来到那个永远供奉着耶稣基督宝血之杯的神庙。圣杯，琼斯博士，他的主人说。基督在最后晚餐中使用的圣杯。那个在受难时接住他鲜血的杯子，并被托付给阿里马太的约瑟。于是，汤姆·霍兰德在电影《夺宝奇兵3：圣战奇兵》中开启了我们英雄寻找圣杯的惊险之旅。现在，汤姆，你很喜欢圣杯，对吧？我在电影《夺宝奇兵3：圣战奇兵》中寻找圣杯。
Crusade. Now you love the Holy Grail, Tom, don't you? I do love the Holy Grail. I love that film. It was my favourite. I know that your favourite is the one of the first three Indiana Jones films we're not covering, The Temple of Doom. So Last Crusade was definitely my favourite. And I think the reason for that is that I was obsessed by the holy grail when i was a child i had i read endlessly about it um it's so much so that actually when i watched um monty python and the holy grail yeah which for those of you who maybe haven't seen it is a comedy mocking the arthurian legends i was much more offended by that than i was by life of brian thought the life of brian was great but i was very very offended i that than I was by Life of Brian. I thought Life of Brian was great, but I was very, very offended. I don't actually find Monty Python and the Holy Grail very funny.
现在你很喜欢圣杯，对吧？我确实很喜欢圣杯。我超爱那部电影。它曾是我的最我知道你最喜欢的前三部印第安纳·琼斯电影中我们没讨论的那部，《魔域奇兵》。所以《圣战奇兵》绝对是我的最爱。我想原因在于我小时候对圣杯着了迷，我读了无数关于它的书，嗯，甚至到了这种地步，实际上当我观看，嗯，蒙提·派森与圣杯时——是的，对于那些可能没看过的人来说，这是一部嘲讽亚瑟王传奇的喜剧——我对那部电影感到的冒犯，远远超过了《布赖恩的生活》。我觉得《布赖恩的生活》很棒，但我感到非常非常被冒犯，我甚至比对《布赖恩的生活》还要生气。我觉得《布赖恩的生活》很棒，但我真的非常非常生气。其实我并不觉得《蒙提·派森与圣杯》有多好笑。
No, I didn't think it was funny at all. I was, as I say, very upset by it. But I think that, of course, I now understand that it comes actually from a position of enormous learning. It was Terry Jones, who's a great medieval enthusiast. Great medieval scholar. And basically, the more you know about the medieval tradition that gave birth to the Holy Grail, the funnier Monty Python and the Holy Grail becomes. And I think that as with the Ark of the Covenant,
不，一点都不好笑。正如我所说，我对此非常沮丧。但我想，当然，我现在明白这其实源于极其渊博的学识。特瑞·琼斯就是这样的人，他是一位伟大的中世纪狂热爱好者。伟大的中世纪学者。基本上，你对孕育了圣杯的中世纪传统了解得越多，《蒙提·派森与圣杯》就越搞笑。我想，正如我们在上一集讨论的
which we talked about in our previous episode, so with the Holy Grail, the holiness kind of is the point because Monty Python are mocking something that is actually rather sacred to them certainly to to terry jones i mean you know you you can only blaspheme something that you believe in yeah and i think that the same is obviously true of the plot of um the last crusade that if the holy grail isn't holy then the plot doesn't work well it's basically in the last crusade it is basically the ark of't work. Well, it's basically, in The Last Crusade, it is basically the Ark of the Covenant
约柜一样，圣杯的神圣性正是关键所在，因为蒙提·派森在嘲笑某种对他们而言实际上相当神圣的东西，对特瑞·琼斯来说尤其如此。我的意思是，你只能对你信仰的事物进行亵渎，对吧？我认为，这一点在《圣战奇兵》的剧情中显然也是成立的，如果圣杯不神圣，那剧情就无法成立。好吧，其实在《圣战奇兵》里，它基本上就是约柜的
all over again. It's a MacGuffin that people seek, but you kind of know what's coming, that it will destroy you, don't you? I mean, they basically reuse the same device. But there's also, are you a big fan of the series? So our overseas listeners won't know what this is, but this is for our British
重演。它是一个人们追寻的麦格芬，但你大概能猜到结果——它会毁灭你，对吧？我的意思是，他们基本上重复使用了相同的设定。不过话说回来，你是这个系列的超级粉丝吗？所以我们的海外听众可能不知道这是什么，但这是献给我们的英国
listeners. The TV series Detectorists, Tom, you're a fan of Detectorists? I love the detectorists yeah so it's a for our overseas listeners it's two um it's set in east anglia isn't it in is it in suffolk suffolk suffolk it's set in suffolk around um i think around sutton who and it's two people with metal detectors who go searching for buried treasure i think last week i did my road trip across england and i i saw the field that i think inspired a lot of those episodes near rendlesham where metal detectors discovered a kind of lost palace but anyway yes but the holy grail appears in in that yeah there's a lovely episode where the central device of it is whether or not they have discovered this cup
听众的。电视剧《寻宝同盟》，汤姆，你是《寻宝同盟》的粉丝吗？我超爱《寻宝同盟》，是的。所以对我们的海外听众来说，这是两个，嗯，故事背景设定在东盎格利亚，对吧？是在萨福克吗？萨福克，萨福克。故事发生在萨福克，在萨顿胡周围，讲的是两个拿着金属探测器寻找埋藏宝藏的人。我想上周我在英国进行公路旅行时，我看到了那个据说是很多剧集灵感来源的田野，就在伦德尔沙姆附近，那里金属探测器发现了一种失落的宫殿。总之，是的，但圣杯在那部剧里也出现了，是的。有一个很棒的剧集，核心情节就是他们是否发现了这个杯子
which actually could have enormous cosmic significance. And that idea, so more than almost any other artefact in history, I would say, the Holy Grail carries this extraordinary charge, doesn't it? I mean, it's fascinated people for centuries. But unlike the Ark of the Covenant, so the Ark of the Covenant is biblically attested. The Holy Grail is not, am I right? It doesn't appear in the Bible at all? Well, the Holy Grail, I think it's a much more mysterious object because the question of where it comes from and what it is, is something that, I mean, it's provided fuel for popular entertainment. We've talked about some of those, but also in the 20th century, it helps to inspire what is probably the single most influential poem written in English of the 20th century, namely The Wasteland.
这实际上可能具有巨大的宇宙意义。这种想法——可以说，比历史上几乎任何其他人工制品都要强烈——圣杯承载着这种非凡的精神能量，不是吗？我的意思是，几个世纪以来它一直让人着迷。但与约柜不同的是，约柜是有圣经记载的。而圣杯则没有，我没说错吧？它根本没有出现在《圣经》中吗？嗯，圣杯，我认为这是一个更加神秘的对象，因为关于它来自哪里以及它是什么的问题，我的意思是，它为大众娱乐提供了素材。我们已经讨论过其中一些，但在20世纪，它还启发了可能是20世纪用英语写的最具影响力的单首诗歌，即《荒原》。
So T.S. Eliot in his notes to The Wasteland is open about this, says that he's inspired by a book called From Ritual to Romance by a very great medievalist called Jesse Weston. And Jesse Weston wrote about the Grail that no theory of the origin of the story can be considered really and permanently satisfactory unless it can offer an explanation of the story as a whole and of the varying forms assumed by the grail why it should be at one time a food providing object of unexplained form at another a dish at one moment the receptacle of streams of blood from a lance at another the cup of the last supper here something wrought of no material substance there a stone and yet everywhere and always possess the same essential significance in each and every form be rightly described as the grail and so this is
因此，T·S·艾略特在《荒原》的注释中对此毫不讳言，他说自己受到了一位伟大的中世纪学者杰西·韦斯顿所著的一本名为《从仪式到传奇》的书的启发。杰西·韦斯顿在谈到圣杯时说，任何关于故事起源的理论，除非能对整个故事以及圣杯呈现的各种形式做出解释，否则都不能被认为是真正且永远令人满意的：为什么它有时是一个来源不明的食物提供对象，有时是一个盘子，一会儿是一支长矛喷射出的血流的容器，一会儿是最后晚餐的杯子，这里由某种无形的物质制成，那里是一块石头，然而在任何地方、任何时候，它都具有相同的本质意义，并且在每一种形式下，都可以被正确地描述为圣杯。所以这是
published in 1920 and the answer that jesse weston gives to her own question is basically that the grail is the survival into christ times of pagan fertility rites. And she talks about there being a wasteland that surrounds the castle of the Fisher King, this mysterious figure who guards the grail. And she sees this idea of a wasteland that then you have to ask the right question of the Fisher King, and then it will bring it will heal the wound that he's been given and bring him back to life and all the land with him and she sees this as being proof for the origin of the grail story and rituals of death and rebirth
在1920年出版的，杰西·韦斯顿对自己提出的问题的回答基本上是：圣杯是异教生育仪式在基督教时代的残余。她谈到了围绕着渔人王城堡的荒原，这个渔人王是一个守护圣杯的神秘人物。她看到了这样一种荒原的观念：你必须向渔人王提出正确的问题，然后它就会治愈他所受的伤，使他连同整片土地一起复活。她认为这是圣杯故事起源于死亡与重生仪式的证据。
and there's a sexual element to this too right that the cup is female kind of sexuality and the and the spear so there's the idea of this sort of this lance piercing the side of Christ, the blood port, and the spear is, she's argued that the spear was basically male sexuality, right? Yes, and the cup is female. And so this is very exciting for T.S. Eliot, who's looking for some way of kind of coordinating his sense of post-war Europe as a wasteland. And so he draws on it very kind of openly. And there are actually, there are two couple of illusions in the wasteland. And so he draws on it very openly. And there are two couple of illusions in the wasteland to this mysterious figure, the Fisher King, who guards the grail. So this brilliant passage, one of my favorite passages from the wasteland, a rat crept softly through
这里面也有性暗示的成分，对吧？杯子代表女性的某种性特征，而长矛——所以有这样一种观点，即这支长矛刺穿了基督的肋旁，鲜血涌出，而长矛，她认为长矛基本上代表了男性的性特征，对吧？是的，杯子代表女性。所以这让T·S·艾略特感到非常兴奋，他正在寻找某种方式来整合他将战后欧洲视为荒原的感觉。因此，他在很大程度上公开地借鉴了这一点。实际上，在《荒原》中有两处隐喻。因此，他在很大程度上公开地借鉴了这一点。在《荒原》中，有两处隐喻指向了这个神秘的人物——守护圣杯的渔人王。这是一个精彩的段落，也是我最喜欢的《荒原》段落之一：一只老鼠轻轻地爬过
the vegetation, dragging its slimy belly on the bank while I was fishing in the dull canal on a winter evening round behind the gas house. It's very T.S. Eliot, the gas house detail, isn't it? Yeah, very, very T.S. Eliot. So, Dominic. Yes. How true is this theory? How likely is it that the grail was the cup that held the blood of Christ or that it was a, you know, derives from pagan fertility rituals or where did it come from?
植被，将它那黏糊糊的肚皮拖在河岸上，当时我正在加气站后面的冬日傍晚里，在那条沉闷的运河里钓鱼。加气站这个细节非常T·S·艾略特，对吧？是的，非常，非常T·S·艾略特。那么，多米尼克。是的。这个理论有多真实？圣杯真的是盛放基督之血的杯子，或者它（你知道的）源自异教的生育仪式，这种可能性有多大？或者它到底是从哪里来的？
What is it? All that stuff. That's what we're looking at today. Very good. Well, so the grail doesn't appear in the Bible, right? The grail does not, there's no cup. And the word grail, you forget that I did French at university. So I know that the word grail, it's kind of, it's rare in kind of 12th century French, but not unknown. Is that right? That's right. So you learned this when you were doing your medieval French course? Of course. Yeah, I absolutely didn't read your notes. Yeah. So grail, as you say, it's a kind of unusual word, but not unknown. And it seems to
它是什么？所有这些东西。这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。非常好。嗯，所以圣杯并没有出现在《圣经》里，对吧？圣杯确实没有，里面没有杯子。而且“grail”这个词，你忘了我在大学里学过法语。所以我知道“grail”这个词，它在12th世纪的法语中算是一种罕见的词，但并非不为人知。是这样吗？是的。所以你是在上中世纪法语课程时学到这一点的？当然。是的，我绝对没有看你的笔记。是的。所以“grail”，正如你所说，是一个有点罕见但并非不为人知的词。它似乎
refer to a kind of large serving platter that's large enough to hold a salmon or a fish. Right. that's large enough to hold a salmon or a fish. And it's a kind of utensil. It's a piece of crockery, basically, and it carries no particular magical or spiritual significance. And the etymology, it seems to derive either from Greek krata, which is a kind of shallow two-handled drinking cup, or brilliantly from the Latin word, gardalis, which was a kind of pot used to hold garum, the fermented fish guts that the Romans used, this equivalent of ketchup. So very exciting. So basically, it has no sacral connotations,
指的是一种大号的浅盘，大到足以放下一条三文鱼或一条鱼。对。大到足以放下一条三文鱼或一条鱼。它是一种器皿。基本上就是一件陶器，没有任何特殊的魔力或精神意义。至于它的词源，它似乎要么源自希腊语“krata”，这是一种浅底的双柄饮酒杯；要么，妙的是，源自拉丁语单词“gardalis”，这是一种用来盛放“garum”的罐子——古罗马人使用的一种发酵鱼肠，相当于他们的番茄酱。所以非常令人兴奋。因此，基本上，在12th世纪，它没有任何神圣的含义，
Dominic, in the 12th century. That's a first on the rest of history. But of course, it does become sacral. I mean, it becomes holy. And so the question, therefore, is how does this process happen? And actually, we can pinpoint very, very precisely when it happens. It happens in the 1180s, the late 1180s. And the guy who makes the grail into something holy is a French writer called Chrétien de Troyes. So Troyes is a city on a town on the river Seine. Chrétien, literally Christian, so the Christian from Troyes. And he's the father really of the chivalric romance, isn't he? And not only the chivalric romance, but there's a case for saying the entire tradition of the novel.
多米尼克，这是“历史的 rest”节目中的头一次。但当然，它确实变得神圣了。我的意思是，它变得神圣了。因此，问题就在于，这个过程是如何发生的？事实上，我们可以非常非常精确地指出它发生的时间。它发生在12th世纪80年代，即12th世纪80年代末。把圣杯变成神圣之物的家伙是一个名叫克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦的法国作家。所以特鲁瓦是塞纳河畔的一个城市或城镇。克雷蒂安，字面意思就是基督徒，也就是来自特鲁瓦的基督徒。他确实可以说是骑士传奇之父，对吧？不仅是骑士传奇，甚至可以说整个小说传统都源于他。
So Dominic, what is French for novel? Romand. So derives from what is French for novel? Romand. So derived from romance? Romance, yeah. Yeah. And so this Romanus originally was the word that was given to the language spoken by Gallo-Romans in the late Roman Empire, which goes on to become French. So the key thing is that Chrétien de Troyes is writing romance, and he's doing that in French, not in Latin. So therefore, it is kind of readily accessible to everybody and not just the
那么，多米尼克，法语里的小说怎么说？Romand。所以它源于法语里的小说怎么说？Romand。所以源自罗马传奇？罗曼语，是的。是的。所以这个“Romanus”最初是用来指代晚期罗马帝国中加洛-罗马人所说的语言的词，后来演变成了法语。所以关键在于，克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦写的是传奇故事，而且他是用法语写的，而不是拉丁语。因此，它对每个人来说都是平易近人的，而不仅仅是
scholars. And he is to Arthurian romance, what Geoffrey of Monmouth, who we talked about in our episode on King Arthur, is to the kind of historical traditions. he is the guy who takes this great corpus of Welsh Celtic traditions and converts it into a form that makes it readily accessible to people across the French-speaking world. And although, as with Geoffrey of Monmouth, Geoffrey's Arthur is recognisably a medieval king, he's not a kind of early medieval king. He's a king from the high Middle Ages. The same is true of Chrétien de Troyes' romances, that although they are set in the Arthurian past, they are actually a reflection of the world in which he is living. The life of the courts, the tournaments, the knightly codes, and perhaps also the specific understandings of
学者们的专利。对于亚瑟王传奇来说，他就像我们在关于亚瑟王的节目中讨论过的蒙茅斯的杰弗里对于历史传统的意义一样。他将这庞大的威尔士凯尔特传统转化为一种让法语世界的普通人都能轻松理解的形式。尽管和蒙茅斯的杰弗里一样，杰弗里笔下的亚瑟王是个显而易见的中世纪国王，但他并不是那种早期中世纪的国王。他是一位高盛中世纪的国王。克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦的传奇故事也是如此，尽管它们以亚瑟王时代为背景，但实际上它们反映的正是他所生活的那个世界。宫廷生活、比武大会、骑士准则，或许还有当时
religion at this period. So Tom, is there one text, one kind of romance from which we get the Grail story with Chrétien de Troyes? Yes, so Chrétien writes a number of famous romances, one of which Lancelot has a huge influence on the whole idea of Lancelot as the kind of the paradigmatic knight. But his most influential by miles is one called Percival, after the name of the hero, which also Chrétien himself, in his introduction to it, calls Le Conte de Graal, the story of the grail. And he wrote that, as I said, in the 1180s. And this is the romance that
对宗教的特定理解。所以，汤姆，有没有哪一部文本、哪一种传奇故事是克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦的圣杯故事的来源？是的，克雷蒂安写了许多著名的传奇故事，其中一部是《兰斯洛特》，它对兰斯洛特作为标准骑士形象的整个概念产生了巨大影响。但对他影响最大的，当属一部以英雄名字命名的《珀西瓦尔》，克雷蒂安自己在序言中也将这部作品称为《圣杯的故事》。正如我所说，他是在12th世纪80年代写下这部作品的。而这部传奇故事
introduces us to the grail as something holy. Although in Chrétien's account, it's not the grail, it's a grail that is holy. So it's kind of key distinction there. It only becomes the holy grail over the next decades that follow. So, Dominic, the plot of Percival. And I'm sure you must have read these. You must have been into King Arthur. I was into this, but Percival, in my mind, and I am hoping you're going to shed some light on this, Percival and Galahad are very confused.
向我们介绍了作为圣物出现的圣杯。尽管在克雷蒂安的叙述中，它不是“那个”圣杯，而是一个圣杯——所以这是一个关键的区别。它在接下来的几十年里才逐渐变成了“圣杯”。那么，多米尼克，《珀西瓦尔》的剧情是怎样的？我确信你一定读过这些。你以前一定很迷亚瑟王。我是很迷这个，但在我的印象中——我希望你能为我解惑——珀西瓦尔和加拉哈德经常被混淆。
And I think that's a feature rather than a bug. The other thing, Tom, is I do like the opera Parsifal, the Wagner opera, which seems to go on, as my wife said, we've sat here for six hours, nothing has happened. People are just singing constantly and moving incredibly slowly around the stage. The grail is there the whole time, but I don't understand what's going on and nothing is happening at all. So that's, I don't want to, I mean, I'm really selling it to the audience.
我认为这是一个特色，而不是一个漏洞。另一件事，汤姆，我确实很喜欢歌剧《帕西法尔》，瓦格纳的这部歌剧，正如我妻子所说，它好像一直在演，我们在这里坐了六个小时，什么都没发生。人们只是在不停地唱歌，在舞台上以极其缓慢的速度移动。圣杯从头到尾都在那里，但我根本不知道发生了什么，什么都没有发生。所以，我并不想——我的意思是，我真是在向听众极力推荐它。
Okay. Okay. Listen, Dominic, we will come to Galahad and we might touch on Percival and Wagner as well. So the plot of Percival, I'll go into some detail because it's incredibly influential on the grail. I mean, basically without this story, we would not have the Holy Grail. Okay. I think. So it begins with this small boy, Percival, who is being brought up in a forest
好吧。好吧。听着，多米尼克，我们会谈到加拉哈德，我们可能也会顺便聊聊珀西瓦尔和瓦格纳。所以《珀西瓦尔》的剧情，我会讲得详细一些，因为它对圣杯传奇产生了极其深远的影响。我的意思是，基本上如果没有这个故事，我们就不会有圣杯。好吧。我认为。所以故事开始于一个小男孩珀西瓦尔，他在森林里被母亲抚养长大
by his mother. And his mother has lost two sons. They've both been knights. They've both been killed. Her husband, Percival's father, has died of grief and of his wounds that he also has sustained from fighting. And so Percival's mother is desperate that Percival doesn't grow up to fulfill his kind of ancestral destiny, namely to become a knight. But inevitably, having set this up, Percival does become a knight because he's wandering through the forest and he suddenly sees these incredible figures in all their armor coming through on horses. He has no idea what they are he's completely dazzled he he asks one of them are you god and the knights explain who they are what they are Percival wants to become a knight and he he goes with them without telling his mother and he has various adventures he has the
。他的母亲失去了两个儿子。他们都曾是骑士，而且都阵亡了。她的丈夫、珀西瓦尔的父亲也因悲伤以及战斗留下的伤痛而去世。因此，珀西瓦尔的母亲极力希望珀西瓦尔不要长大后去实现他祖先的命运——也就是成为一名骑士。但不可避免地，既然设定了这一点，珀西瓦尔还是成为了一名骑士，因为他在森林里游荡时，突然看到这些身穿盔甲、骑着马的威风凛凛的人物从眼前经过。他根本不知道他们是什么人，他被彻底震撼了。他问其中一个人：“你是上帝吗？”骑士们解释了他们是谁、是什么。珀西瓦尔也想成为一名骑士，于是他没有告诉母亲就跟着他们走了，并经历了一系列冒险。整个故事的
whole kind of comedy of it is that he's he's somebody who's wholly ignorant of what's going on and so in a sense it's it's a kind of story of how uh someone you know a bumpkin becomes a sophisticated chivalric figure yeah and he has to although he has a completely natural aptitude for fighting for um doing everything that a knight should in tournaments and so on he has to be instructed in what is expected of a knight. And so he's aware of this and he hunts out people who he thinks will be good tutors. And among the lessons that he's taught by his tutors is that a good knight should not jabber too much. He should not ask needless questions. He should know when to hold
喜剧效果就在于，他对正在发生的事情完全一无所知，所以从某种意义上说，这是一个关于一个乡巴佬如何变成一个老练的骑士阶层人物的故事，是的。尽管他在战斗和履行骑士职责（比如参加比武大会等）方面有着完全天生的才能，但他仍然必须接受关于骑士行为准则的指导。因此他意识到了这一点，并开始寻找他认为会成为好导师的人。他的导师教导他的课程之一就是：一个好骑士不应该废话太多。不应该问多余的问题。应该知道什么时候该闭
his tongue. Is that a hint from you tom to uh to your co-presenter no not at all i mean obviously that would make percival a terrible podcaster if he just sat there not asking questions or not being allowed to say anything but as a knight this is the lesson that he takes on board and this is very important so he's coming on leaps and bounds as a knight he's you know knocking rival knights out of their saddles and rescuing ladies and doing all the things that a knight errant should and heuing ladies and doing all the things that a knight errant should. And he's out and he reaches a river and there he meets two men, one of whom Dominic is fishing. And this man, who is the fisher king, it turns out, offers Percival lodging.
嘴。这是你对你的联合主持人的暗示吗，汤姆？没有，完全不是。我的意思是，很显然，如果珀西瓦尔只是坐在那里不问问题或者不被允许说任何话，那他就会成为一个糟糕的播客主持人。但作为一个骑士，这是他铭记于心的教训，这非常重要。所以他的骑士技能突飞猛进，你知道的，他把对手从马鞍上撞下来，拯救淑女，做着一个游侠骑士应该做的一切，拯救淑女，做着一个游侠骑士应该做的一切。他走了出来，来到了一条河边，在那里他遇到了两个人，其中一个人，多米尼克，正在钓鱼。这个后来被证明是渔人王的男人，邀请珀西瓦尔去借宿。
And he says to Percival, ride up through the cleft in that rock. And when you come to the top, you'll see a castle in a valley ahead of you. This is where I live, near the river and the woods. And Percival rides up, looks around, can't see the castle at all. No sign of it. And then suddenly it materializes. And so you have this sense of it that he's passing into the dimension of something, of the weird, of the supernatural, of the strange. So he rides into the castle and there he discovers not the
他对珀西瓦尔说，骑马穿过那块岩石的裂缝。当你到达山顶时，你会看到前方山谷里有一座城堡。这就是我住的地方，靠近河边和树林。珀西瓦尔骑马上去，四处张望，根本看不到城堡。一点痕迹也没有。然后它突然凭空出现了。所以你会有一种感觉，他正在进入某种维度，一种诡异的、超自然的、陌生的维度。于是他骑马进入城堡，在那里他发现的不是
Fisher King, but the man who turns out to be the father of the Fisher King, who is terribly wounded, can't get up off the couch that he's lying on. And he's in this great hall. There's a blazing fire. Chrétien tells us that 400 men could have sat around the fire and each would have been warmed by the flames. So it's a tremendous place, clearly a place charged with adventure. And immediately strange things start happening. So a magical sword is brought to Percival and he's told, this has been waiting for you. And it's kind of strapped onto him and it's the best sword he's ever seen. It's all very kind of Aragorn he's chatting away to the to the wounded king on his couch and then I will describe what happens in Cretien's own words while they
渔人王，而是后来证明是渔人王父亲的那个人，他伤势严重，根本无法从躺着的躺椅上站起来。他正身处这个大厅里。里面燃着熊熊大火。克雷蒂安告诉我们，400人可以围坐在火堆旁，每个人都能被火焰温暖。所以这是一个宏伟的地方，显然是一个充满冒险的地方。紧接着，奇怪的事情发生了。一把神奇的剑被拿给珀西瓦尔，并告诉他，这把剑一直在等他。它被系在他身上，这是他见过的最好的剑。这感觉非常像阿拉贡。他与躺椅上受伤的国王闲聊着，然后我将用克雷蒂安自己的话来描述接下来发生的事情：当他们
were talking a boy from a chamber clutching a white lance by the middle of the shaft came out and passed between the fire and the lord and his guest a drop of blood issued from the tip of the lance's shaft and right down to the boy's hand this red drop ran now persifal obviously is dying to know what is going on yeah there's a lot going on there i think tom he remembers his his coaching and so he he doesn't ask what's going on then two other boys appear and they're holding candlesticks and And then comes a girl, very, very beautiful girl, beautifully dressed. And she, Chrétien says, is holding a grail. So not the grail, a grail.
谈话时，一个房间里的男孩手里紧紧抓着一根白色的长矛的中间部位走了出来，从火堆和领主以及他的客人之间走过。一滴血从长矛矛杆的尖端渗出，一路流到了男孩的手上。现在，珀西瓦尔显然渴望知道发生了什么，是的，那里发生了很多事情，我想，汤姆，他想起了他的教导，所以他没有问到底发生了什么。接着，另外两个男孩出现了，他们手里拿着烛台。然后走过来一个女孩，非常非常漂亮，穿着华丽。克雷蒂安说，她手里拿着一个圣杯。所以不是“那个”圣杯，而是一个圣杯。
And when she comes in holding this grail, this kind of brilliant light radiates the entire room so that all the candles lose their brightness. And then after her comes another girl holding a silver trencher and the grail cretin says which went ahead was made of fine pure gold and in it was set precious stones of many kinds the richest and most precious in the earth or the sea those in the grail surpassed all other jewels and the grail then magically serves all the assembled guests it kind of provides food for them so it's a kind of mobile magical food dispenser right and still Percival doesn't ask what's going on I mean you think come
当她走进来拿着这个圣杯时，这种灿烂的光芒照亮了整个房间，以至于所有的蜡烛都失去了它们的光彩。在她之后，又走过来另一个女孩，手里拿着一个银托盘。克雷蒂安说，走在前面的圣杯是由纯净的金子制成的，上面镶嵌着各种各样的宝石，是大地或海洋中最丰富、最珍贵的宝石，圣杯上的宝石超过了所有其他的珠宝。接着，圣杯神奇地为所有聚集的客人们提供服务，它为他们提供食物，所以它是一个移动的、神奇的食物分发器，对吧？然而珀西瓦尔仍然没有问到底发生了什么。我的意思是，你会想，拜托，问啊，问这些问题，这到底是怎么一回事？但他没有问，他上床睡觉了，而且他仍然没有问到底发生了什么。当他醒来时，城堡空无一人。
on ask ask the questions what what the hell is this all about but he doesn't and he goes to bed and he still hasn't asked what's going on and he wakes up and the castle is completely empty. And it becomes apparent that his seeming lack of curiosity has been understood as a lack of compassion because he hasn't asked the wounded king, how did you get wounded? He hasn't asked about the grail. And this gets bundled up with another piece of devastating news he's brought, namely that his mother has died of grief because he's gone away without telling her. And he comes back to Camelot feeling a bit crestfallen and he sits down at the round table. And as he does so, a loathsome damsel appears. I remember her from the stories. And she denounces Percival in front of all the knights of the round table and King Arthur and
很显然，他表面上的缺乏好奇心被理解为了缺乏同情心，因为他没有问受伤的国王：“你是怎么受伤的？”他没有询问关于圣杯的事情。这伴随着另一个毁灭性的消息传到了他耳中——他的母亲因为他没有告别就离去而悲伤过度去世了。他回到卡米洛特时感到有些沮丧，并在圆桌旁坐了下来。正当他这么做时，一个令人讨厌的少女出现了。我从故事里还记得她。她在圆桌骑士和亚瑟王面前谴责了珀西瓦尔，并
she says to Percival that ladies will lose their husbands lands will be laid waste girls will be left in distress and orphaned and many knights will die and all these evils will happen because of you now it's important to say this is not because of any supernatural connection between the Fisher King or his wounded father and their lands. It's because the wounded king cannot adequately defend his lands. That is why there will be all this suffering. So at this point, there is no supernatural connection between the idea of the wasteland and the king. Okay, right. Just bear that in mind. Percival is so devastated by this that he basically,
对珀西瓦尔说，淑女们将失去丈夫，土地将沦为荒地，女孩们将陷入绝望成为孤儿，许多骑士将死去，而所有这些灾难都将因你而起。现在必须说明的是，这并不是因为渔人王或他受伤的父亲与他们的土地之间存在什么超自然的联系。而是因为受伤的国王无法充分保卫他的土地。这就是为什么会有所有这些苦难的原因。所以在这一点上，荒原的概念和国王之间并没有超自然的联系。好吧，明白了。只要记住这一点。珀西瓦尔对此感到痛不欲生，以至于他基本上
he loses all his faith in God. He just roams around kind of fighting and doing his stuff. Five years pass, and he's riding along in full armor. He comes across five knights, ten ladies. They're walking barefoot. They're wearing hair shirts. They're in procession. They say to Percival, why are you in armor? Why are you riding around? Don't you know it's Good Friday, the day on which Christ suffered death? Percival, why are you in armor? Why are you riding around? Don't you know it's Good Friday, the day on which Christ suffered death? And Percival is ashamed by this, shocked by this, and he says that he will seek redemption. And he's guided by the knights and the ladies to go and seek instruction from a nearby hermit who is conveniently located just around the corner. And even more amazingly, this hermit turns out to be Percival's uncle. What are the chances, Tom?
对上帝失去了所有信仰。他只是四处游荡，打打杀杀，做着他那一套。五年过去了，他穿着全身盔甲骑马前行。他遇到了五个骑士，十个女士。他们赤脚行走。他们穿着苦修士的粗麻衬衫。他们正在进行游行。他们对珀西瓦尔说：“你为什么穿着盔甲？你为什么到处骑马？难道你不知道今天是耶稣受难日，是基督为我们受死并殉难的日子吗？”珀西瓦尔，你为什么穿着盔甲？你为什么到处骑马？难道你不知道今天是耶稣受难日，是基督为我们受死并殉难的日子吗？珀西瓦尔对此感到羞愧，感到震惊，并表示他将寻求救赎。在这些骑士和女士的指引下，他去寻求附近一个隐士的教导，这个隐士非常凑巧地就住在拐角处。更令人惊奇的是，这位隐士竟然是珀西瓦尔的叔叔。这几率有多大，汤姆？
Absolutely stunning. And this hermit, Percival's uncle, tells Percival the story of the grail. And he says that the grail is holy. This is where you get the idea of the grail being holy. Right. And the hermit instructs Percival in how to be a godly knight, that he has to defend girls, widows, orphans. And Percival, we're told by Cretia, came to recognize that God received death and was crucified on the Friday. And at Easter, most worthily, Percival received communion. And presumably, this is setting him up to go back to the Grail Castle
简直惊人。这位隐士，也就是珀西瓦尔的叔叔，把圣杯的故事讲给了珀西瓦尔听。他告诉珀西瓦尔，圣杯是神圣的。这就是你得出圣杯是神圣的这一概念的源头。对。隐士教导珀西瓦尔如何成为一个虔诚的骑士，他必须保护少女、寡妇、孤儿。我们从克雷蒂安那里得知，珀西瓦尔开始认识到上帝是在星期五遭受死亡并被钉死在十字架上的。而在复活节，珀西瓦尔最值得赞美地领了圣餐。据推测，这一切都在为他重返圣杯城堡
and ask the questions that he should have asked, and everything will be all right. But at this point, Cretia breaks off and the story is left uncompleted. That is an unbelievably disappointing way. It's a massive cliffhanger. Yeah. So we don't ever find out. I mean, I would say, Tom, you know exactly what I'm going to say, I imagine, which is that all that stuff with shafts, tips of things, a comely maiden holding a cup, that there's a very obvious explanation for what's going on here. That it's all about fertility and actually that Jesse Weston stuff is not. That's what you'd say. That is what I'd say.
并提出他本该提出的问题做准备，这样一切都会好起来的。但就在这时，克雷蒂安笔锋一转，故事戛然而止，留下了悬念。这真是一个令人难以置信的令人失望的结局。这是一个巨大的悬念。是的。所以我们永远不会知道。我的意思是，我想说，汤姆，你肯定知道我要说什么，我猜，那就是所有那些关于矛杆、矛尖、一个美丽的少女拿着一个杯子的情节，对于这里发生的事情有一个非常显而易见的解释。这一切都与生育能力有关，实际上杰西·韦斯顿的那些理论并非如此。这就是你会说的话。这确实是我要说的话。
Well, I mean, it doesn't take any great, I don't have to, it doesn't take any penetrating insight for me to come up with that. I mean, that's surely blindingly obvious. Before we come to that, the question of what this might all mean, let's just kind of finish off the account of how the Grail legend came to emerge. Because all Cretien's romances were massively popular and influential, but this was the most influential of the lot. I think precisely because it was left unfinished and therefore it was really, really tantalizing. And over the course of the decades that follow, basically five decades that follow, there are endless attempts to rewrite it. And so you have two particularly influential sequels. One of them is written by a guy called Robert de Boron. And he's writing not a romance,
好吧，我的意思是，这不需要任何伟大的，我不需要，这不需要任何深刻的洞察力我才能得出这个结论。我的意思是，这难道不是显而易见的吗？在我们探讨这个之前，关于这一切可能意味着什么的问题，让我们先把圣杯传奇是如何演变出来的这段梳理完。因为克雷蒂安所有的传奇故事都广受欢迎且极具影响力，但这一部是其中影响力最大的。我想正是因为它没有完结，所以才真的、真的很引人入胜。在随后的几十年里，基本上是随后的五十年里，人们进行了无数次重写它的尝试。因此，你有了两个特别有影响力的续集。其中之一是由一个名叫罗贝尔·德·博龙的人写的。他写的不是传奇故事，
but he specifies a history of the Grail. So his account is focused not on the romance of finding it, not the quest for the grail, but the grail itself. And he is the person who introduces Joseph of Arimathea, who is a biblical figure. Joseph of Arimathea is the person who takes Christ's body after the crucifixion and buries it in the tomb. But there are kind of various late gospels in which Joseph of Arimathea plays a leading role. Robert de Boron draws on these traditions. In his account, we learn how the grail is the vessel in which Christ broke the bread at the Last Supper. It was taken from the house where the disciples had met by one of the Jews who then take Christ prisoner. This Jew gives it to Pilate, who in turn gives it to Joseph of Arimathea. Joseph then takes this cup
而是明确了一部圣杯的历史。因此，他的叙述重点不在于寻找它的传奇，不在于对圣杯的追寻，而在于圣杯本身。他是那个引入了阿里马太的约瑟的人，这是一个《圣经》人物。阿里马太的约瑟是那个在耶稣受难后收敛基督的遗体并将其安葬在墓穴中的人。但是有一些晚期的福音书，在其中阿里马太的约瑟扮演了主要角色。罗贝尔·德·博龙借鉴了这些传统。在长篇叙述中，我们了解到圣杯是基督在最后晚餐中分发面包的容器。它被将基督抓走的一个犹太人从门徒聚会的屋子里拿走了。这个犹太人把它交给了彼拉多，彼拉多又把它交给了阿里马太的约瑟。然后约瑟把这个杯子带到了
to the crucifixion, and he gathers the blood of Christ that's flowing from the wound where the Roman soldier has stabbed it with the spear, and he gathers it in the grail. And he establishes this kind of lineage of people who guard the grail. So the Fisher King is actually Joseph of Arimathea's brother-in-law, a man called Bronn. And so he's incredibly venerable. I mean, he's lived for centuries and centuries and centuries. And he lives in the castle with his companions who are called the Company of the Grail. And in his history, Percival does return to the castle of the Fisher King, and he does ask the right question. And Percival becomes the Keeper of the Grail. And Bronn departs from the world, having taught,
十字架受难的现场，他收集了从罗马士兵用长矛刺伤的伤口中流出的基督的鲜血，并将它们收集在圣杯中。他建立了一条守护圣杯的人的血脉谱系。因此，渔人王实际上是阿里马太的约瑟的连襟，一个名叫布朗的人。所以他极其德高望重。我的意思是，他已经活了几个世纪、几个世纪、几个世纪。他住在城堡里，与他的同伴们生活在一起，这些人被称为圣杯同伴。在他的历史中，珀西瓦尔确实回到了渔人王的城堡，并且他确实提出了正确的问题。珀西瓦尔成为了圣杯的守护者。布朗离开了这个世界，用
in Robert de Boron's words, having taught Percival the sacred words that Joseph of Arimathea had taught him and which I cannot and must not tell you. So there you have this idea of the Holy Grail being the cup of Christ, guardians, secrets, all that kind of stuff. The second key text that is written as a sequel to Chrétien de Troyes is by a German writer called Wolfram von Eschenbach. And this is a very radical reworking of basically the French traditions. And in it, the Fisher King is a man called Anne Fortas, and he's been wounded through his genitals. So introducing a eunuch into the story, which will gladden the hearts of all
罗贝尔·德·博龙的话来说，他教会了珀西瓦尔阿里马太的约瑟教给他的那些神圣的话语，而这些话语我不能也不会告诉你。所以在这里，你有了这样一种理念：圣杯是基督的杯子、守护者、秘密，所有诸如此类的东西。作为克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦故事续集而写的第二个关键文本是由一个名叫沃尔夫拉姆·冯·埃森巴赫的德国作家创作的。这是对法国传统的一个非常激进的改写。在其中，渔人王是一个名叫安福塔斯的男人，他生殖器受伤了。因此，故事中引入了一个太监的角色，这将会让所有
Reston's History listeners, as punishment for an extramarital affair. The lance is the spear that is carried in the procession. It's the spear with which the Fisher King has been wounded. The grail itself is not a cup. It's not a dish. It's nothing like that. It's a stone. And Parzival is part of a long kind of line of, it's very holy blood and holy grail.
“历史的 rest”听众感到高兴，作为对他发生婚外情的惩罚。长矛是游行队伍中携带的矛。正是这根长矛刺伤了渔人王。圣杯本身不是一个杯子。它不是一个盘子。它完全不属于这些。它是一块石头。帕西瓦尔是一长串，这是非常神圣的血统和圣杯。
So his ancestors include Vespasian, the Roman emperor. It includes a Trojan prince. And he in turn is the father of Lohengrin, who will be the hero of a Wagner opera, and a long line of keepers of the grail. So in other words, a sacred bloodline. So it's Eschenbach's version that Wagner was really... Yes. So that's what Wagner draws on. Yeah. So these are the two key accounts. There are various other accounts as well, which add further ingredients. So one of them, for instance, adds the detail that the lance is, and this is basically what becomes canonical except in von Eschenbach's version, that the lance is the spear of a Roman soldier called Longinus,
所以他的祖先包括罗马皇帝韦斯帕赞。其中包括一位特洛伊王子。而他反过来又是罗恩格林的父亲，罗恩格林将成为瓦格纳歌剧中的英雄，也是一长串圣杯守护者的祖先。换句话说，是一个神圣的血统。所以瓦格纳真正借鉴的是埃森巴赫的版本……是的。所以这就是瓦格纳所汲取的灵感来源。是的。这些是两个关键的记述。还有其他各种各样的记述，它们增添了更多的元素。例如，其中一个版本增添了这样的细节：长矛是——除了冯·埃森巴赫的版本外，这基本上成了正统版本——长矛是一个名叫朗基努斯的罗马士兵的武器，
who used it to stab the side of Christ. So you have the grail, which is gathering the blood of Christ and was used at the last supper, and you have the spear. So it's all about the passion of Christ. You also have a very detailed romantic account, which folds in the whole of the round table. So the quest for the grail becomes something that's not just exclusive to Percival, but all the knights of the round table. And in this version, the person who wins it is not Percival, but the knight that you mentioned earlier, Dominic, Galahad. And Galahad is the son of Sir Lancelot, the best of Arthur's knights, and the girl who keeps the grail. So you remember in Cretia's account, it's a girl who carries the grail. Lancelot in this sleeps with her and has this son, Galahad, who is perfect. And what you have in this romance, Lancelot does not get the grail because of his
他用它刺穿了基督的肋旁。所以你有收集基督之血并在最后晚餐中使用的圣杯，你还有那根长矛。所以这一切都围绕着基督的受难。你还有一个非常详细的爱情故事，它将整个圆桌骑士团都卷了进来。因此，对圣杯的追寻不再只是珀西瓦尔一个人的专利，而是所有圆桌骑士的事。在这个版本中，赢得圣杯的人不是珀西瓦尔，而是你刚才提到的那个骑士，多米尼克，加拉哈德。加拉哈德是亚瑟王麾下最优秀的骑士兰斯洛特爵士与守护圣杯的女孩所生的儿子。所以你记得在克雷蒂安的故事里，是一个女孩拿着圣杯。兰斯洛特在这个版本中与她同房，并生下了加拉哈德，他是完美的。而在这个传奇故事中，兰斯洛特之所以没有得到圣杯，是因为他与
affair with Guinevere. So he's been having an affair with Guinevere, the wife of King Arthur, for 24 years. And so he approaches where the grail is and gets hit by a kind of great fiery blast and is knocked out for 24 days, one day for each of the year that he's been having an affair with Guinevere. And basically, Galahad wins it because he has the right lineage to win it. He is descended from the grail keeper. He's descended from Lancelot, who was Arthur's best knight. So he's the fusion of the best of the chivalric and the holiness that is required for a keeper of the Grail. And so when he comes to Camelot, his approach is signaled by all kinds of supernatural occurrences. And his inscription appears by magic on the round table. There's this empty seat, the siege perilous, where only the best knight can
桂妮维亚有染。所以他跟亚瑟王的妻子桂妮维亚有染长达24年之久。因此，当他走近圣杯所在的地方时，被一股巨大的炽热烈焰击中，昏迷了24天，正好对应他与桂妮维亚有染的年数，每年一天。基本上，加拉哈德赢得了圣杯，因为他拥有赢得圣杯的正确血统。他是圣杯守护者的后代。他是兰斯洛特的后代，而兰斯洛特是亚瑟王麾下最优秀的骑士。所以他是骑士精神与圣杯守护者所需的神圣性的完美融合。因此，当他来到卡米洛特时，他的到来预示着各种超自然现象的发生。他的名字神奇地出现在圆桌上。那里有一个空座位，即“危险座位”，只有最优秀的骑士才能
sit or he will be consumed and vanish into hell. Galahad sits there and it's all fine. A sword in a stone floats down the river miraculously. And this kind of lettering on it says, only the best knight who is destined to win the grail can draw it. Galahad draws it, and so it becomes apparent. And so this is the stuff that then feeds into the version of Arthurian legends that's best known to English speakers, Valerie's account. And basically that's the account that has passed into the kind of... Just to be clear, you can't really have both Percival and Galahad, can you? It's kind of either or, is that right?
坐在那里，否则他将被吞噬并坠入地狱。加拉哈德坐在那里，一切都安然无恙。一把插在石头里的剑奇迹般地顺流而下漂了过来。剑上刻着这样的字样：只有注定要赢得圣杯的最优秀的骑士才能拔出它。加拉哈德拔出了它，于是真相大白。所以这些内容随后融入了英语世界最熟悉的亚瑟王传说版本中，即瓦勒里的记述。基本上，这就是那个流传下来的版本……需要明确的是，你不可能同时拥有珀西瓦尔和加拉哈德，对吧？这基本上是二选一，是这样吗？
Yeah, pretty much. So Percival is in this account with another knight called Bors, both of whom are kings in this account. They do end up kind of attaining the grail. But it is Galahad who has a particular experience of the grail that perhaps we could come to in the second half, because the spin that is given on what exactly it means for Galahad to win the grail is quite an important part, I think, in explaining what is going on here. Excellent. Well, I mean, to put it in simple terms, the next line of your notes, Tom, reads, WTF is going on. And that is what we will explore in the second half of this episode.
是的，差不多是这样。所以珀西瓦尔在这个故事里和另一个名叫博尔斯的骑士在一起，这两个人在这个故事里都是国王。他们最终确实得到了圣杯。但加拉哈德对圣杯有着某种特殊的体验，也许我们可以在下半部分探讨一下，因为对于加拉哈德赢得圣杯到底意味着什么所赋予的转折，我认为这在解释到底发生了什么方面是非常重要的一部分。太好了。好吧，我的意思是，简单来说，汤姆你的笔记上的下一行写的是：这到底是什么鬼。而这正是我们将在本集下半部分探讨的内容。
See you after the break. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name. Your cafe name. Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like
我们中场休息后见。奇娅拉，在意大利语中是聪明的意思。只可惜你的咖啡师不会拼写。所以你只能随便说个假名字。你常去的咖啡馆名字。茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢什么浓缩咖啡饮料
anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde.
不管怎样？现在改拿铁的订单还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了，因为你可以直接在家煮咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。你根本不用想这些，因为你完全可以在家里自己做浓缩咖啡。立即访问 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. If you've seen Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade, you'll remember that when they finally get to, it's basically Petra, isn't it? It's Petra and Jordan. And the adventurers think they've got the grail,
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《剩下的都是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将带你一窥娱乐幕后，揭秘这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《剩下的都是历史》。如果你看过《夺宝奇兵3：圣杯奇兵》，你就会记得当他们最终到达那个地方时，基本上就是佩特拉，对吧？那是约旦的佩特拉。探险家们以为他们找到了圣杯，
but then there's a remarkable twist at the end, Tom, which nobody could possibly have anticipated. Now, no doubt you've got all kinds of remarkable twists in store, but you were going to explain exactly what is going on. Because when I hear all this stuff about lances, piercings, cups, I mean, my mind only works one way. You think fertility symbols. I do, Tom. It amazes you to know that. But you've got all kinds of stuff because I've seen your notes. So I know there's all kinds of weird and wonderful things going on in the second half of this episode. We tend to think of this now uniquely in Freudian, Jungian terms, don't we?
但故事最后却有一个令人惊叹的转折，汤姆，这是任何人都不可能预料到的。毫无疑问，你准备了各种精彩的转折，但你打算给我们详细解释一下这到底是怎么回事。因为当我听到所有这些关于长矛、刺穿、圣杯的事情时，我的脑子里只有一种想法。你觉得那是生育象征。确实如此，汤姆。你可能会对此感到惊讶。但你准备了各种各样的料，因为我看过你的笔记。所以我知道在这个下半集里，会有各种光怪陆离、精彩绝伦的内容。我们现在倾向于用一种独特的弗洛伊德式、荣格式的视角来思考这个问题，对吧？
Well, I think it's clear that the fascination that the Grail has held for people over the episode we tend to think of this now uniquely in kind of freudian jungian terms don't we well i think it's clear that the fascination that the grail has held for people over the course of the 20th and 21st centuries is fundamentally wrapped up in the sense of it being mysterious i mean that the sense that there is there is a kind of truth there a secret there that if only you can grasp it then you'll understand it and it's kind of written into the fabric of the romances itself. I mean, they talk about the secrets of the grail. You have to win it. And so I think that there've been kind of three really influential theories that have grown up over the past century or so to explain it. And one is absolutely the one that you were alluding to, the idea that it's the kind of which Jung pushes himself, the idea that it's a kind of which Jung pushes himself. The idea that it's a kind of a universal symbol,
嗯，我认为很明显，在20世纪和21世纪的过程中，圣杯对人们所产生的这种吸引力，本集节目中我们倾向于以一种独特的弗洛伊德式、荣格式的视角来看待这个问题，对吧？嗯，我认为很明显，在过去一个世纪左右的时间里，圣杯对人们保持的这种吸引力，从根本上与它所具有的神秘感交织在一起——我的意思是，那种其中蕴含着某种真理、某种秘密的感觉，只要你能掌握它，你就能理解它，而这种感觉本身就写在传奇故事的肌理之中。我的意思是，他们谈论的是圣杯的秘密。你必须赢得它。所以我想，在过去的一个世纪左右里，涌现出了三种真正有影响力的理论来解释它。其中之一绝对就是你刚才提到的那种，即荣格本人所推崇的观点，即它是一种……荣格本人所推崇的观点，即它是一种普遍的象征，
a key to all the mythologies. Did you ever read Joseph Campbell's books on mythology? So Joseph Campbell, his book, The Hero with a Thousand Faces inspired George Lucas, who was the guy who came up with the idea of Indiana Jones and for the Star Wars, yeah. Yeah, so he wrote a four-volume history of mythology and his last one was called, I think, Creative Mythology. Eschenbach's Parzival was central to that, this idea of the Grail as
是所有神话的钥匙？你读过约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）关于神话的书吗？约瑟夫·坎贝尔的著作《千面英雄》启发了乔治·卢卡斯，他就是构思《夺宝奇兵》和《星球大战》点子的人，对吧。对，所以他写了一部四卷本的神话史，他的最后一卷叫做《创造性神话》（Creative Mythology）。埃森巴赫（Eschenbach）的《帕西法尔》（Parzival）就是其中的核心，这种将圣杯视为……的观点
a symbol that explains and symbolizes everything about the relationship of humanity to the supernatural, the mythological realms. But the problem with that, of course, is that I think if you are trying to explain it in historical terms, because that explains everything, it explains nothing. So, I mean, it might work in terms of psychology, but I don't think it works as historical explanation. The other very popular theory that we have explored in a previous episode is the one that is best exemplified by Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, and then by Dan Brown, The Da Vinci Code. The idea of the Holy Grail as a secret, perhaps it's the bloodline of Christ, the Holy Grail becomes the Songraal, the royal bloodline. And again, in our episode on
一个解释并象征着人类与超自然、神话领域关系的象征。但当然，这里的问题在于，如果你试图用历史的角度来解释它，因为这可以解释一切，也就意味着什么也没解释。所以，我的意思是，它或许在心理学上讲得通，但我认为它作为历史解释是行不通的。我们曾在之前的一期节目中探讨过另一个非常受欢迎的理论，这个理论在《圣血与圣杯》（Holy Blood and Holy Grail）以及丹·布朗的《达芬奇密码》中得到了最好的体现。也就是将圣杯视为一个秘密——也许它是基督的血脉，“圣杯”（Holy Grail）变成了“皇室血脉”（Sangraal，即王室血脉）。同样，在我们关于……的节目中，
The Da Vinci Code, we explored the inadequacies of that as a historical explanation for what the Grail might have been. And then we come back to this idea that I mentioned at the start of the program, the one that so excited T.S. Eliot, Jesse Weston's idea, that it's all about fertility rituals derived from paganism. And specifically, of course, because these are Celtic traditions, Celtic stories, Arthur is a figure from pre-Anglo-Saxon Britain. The mythology, presumably, therefore, if this theory is correct, must be Welsh. And there's a guy, a scholar, R.S. Loomis, in the mid-20th century, who particularly argued that the Grail is a Christianization of Welsh mythology. And he focuses particularly on this figure called
我们探讨了《达芬奇密码》作为圣杯可能之历史解释的不足之处。然后我们回到了我在节目开始时提到的那个观点——那个让T·S·埃利奥特（T.S. Eliot）兴奋不已的杰西·韦斯顿（Jesse Weston）的观点，即这一切都关乎源自异教的生育仪式。当然，具体来说，因为这些是凯尔特人的传统、凯尔特人的故事，亚瑟是前盎格鲁-撒克逊不列颠时期的人物。因此，如果这个理论是正确的，那么神话据推测一定来自威尔士。在20世纪中期，有一位名叫R·S·鲁米斯（R.S. Loomis）的学者，他特别提出圣杯是对威尔士神话的基督教化改造。他特别关注一个名叫……的人物，
Bran the Blessed, who is kind is involved with a cauldron that is able to bring the dead back to life. And so this idea that perhaps the grail is a cauldron, there's also the idea that Bran himself loses his head. It speaks prophecy. It ends up being buried where the Tower of London is built. Perhaps Bran's head is in some way the Holy Grail. So all this kind of stuff is being teased now there are there are kind of problems with this namely that the idea so the jesse western idea that the wasteland is kind of central to the myth the reason that i emphasized that in parsifal in cretien de trois telling of it that there's no supernatural link between the fisher
布兰祝福者（Bran the Blessed），他与一口能够让死者复活的大锅有关。因此，这种认为圣杯或许是一口大锅的观点，还有一种观点认为布兰本人失去了脑袋。它会预言。最终它被埋在了伦敦塔建造的地方。也许布兰的头在某种程度上就是圣杯。所以现在所有这些乱七八糟的线索都被挑明了，这里面其实存在一些问题，也就是杰西·韦斯顿的观点，即荒原是神话的核心——我之所以在克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦（Chrétien de Troyes）对《帕西法尔》的叙述中强调这一点，是因为渔夫国王与他周围的荒原之间并没有超自然的联系，
king and the wastelands around him, that it's simply the result of kind of depredations following on from the fact that he can't defend his lands. The idea that there is a supernatural link is medieval, but it's very late. So in other words, if that tradition is coming from pagan sources, you would expect it to be the other way around, but it isn't. So that kind of, I think, undermines that theory. The other problem with so all the arguments uh loomis's argument that this is bran the blessed and his cauldron
这纯粹是他无法保卫自己的土地而带来的破坏所导致的后果。这种存在超自然联系的观点确实存在于中世纪，但那是很晚才出现的。换句话说，如果这个传统源自异教源头，你本会期望因果关系是倒过来的，但事实并非如此。所以我想，这就削弱了那种理论。另一个问题在于——所以所有的论点，嗯，鲁米斯的论点，即这是布兰祝福者和他的大锅、
his head or whatever is firstly that the grail initially is is you know it's not a a cup certainly not a cauldron it's a platter and also so far as we know there is no translation of the legends of bran into french in the Middle Ages. You're persuading me. It's not Welsh. It seems very implausible to me. But if it's not from... Let me just say, on the topic of the Last Crusade, there was also, in the 50s, there was a theory that it came from Iran. Oh, interesting. Again, for absolutely nonsensical reasons.
他的头或别的什么——首先是圣杯最初并不是……你知道的，它不是一个杯子，更绝对不是一口大锅，它是一个盘子；其次，据我们所知，中世纪并没有将布兰的传奇翻译成法语。你这是在说服我。它不是威尔士的。在我看来这非常难以置信。但如果它不是来自……顺便说一句，关于《圣杯奇兵》，在50年代还有一种理论认为它来自伊朗。哦，有趣。同样，理由绝对荒谬。
Okay. I mean, I don't want to offend Ali Ansari, who would, who of course be very keen to know that the holy grail is actually iranian but that that perhaps might tie it in with the idea that that it came from petra or from turkey or wherever uh that you get in the holy grail perhaps that's where they got the idea you get in the last crusade yeah um so okay where does it come from then or does chretien to try he doesn't just dream it up i think he does oh crikey i mean i think it's that simple and i think that that what is interesting is that all these stories all these motifs the fisher king the lads the holy grail does ram rathair all of it basically comes in a essentially a kind of 50 60 year period from the 1180s through to the first decades of the 13th century.
好吧。我的意思是，我可不想冒犯阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari），他当然会非常急切地想知道圣杯其实是伊朗的——但也许这可以与它来自佩特拉、土耳其或其他地方的观点联系起来，你在《圣杯奇兵》里也能看到这种说法，也许这就是他们获得灵感的地方，你在《圣杯奇兵》里能看到，是的。嗯，好吧，那它到底是从哪里来的呢？难道克雷蒂安·德·特鲁瓦（Chrétien de Troyes）不是凭空想象出来的吗？我觉得他就是。哦，天哪，我的意思是，我觉得事情就是这么简单。我认为有趣的是，所有这些故事、所有这些母题——渔夫国王、长矛、圣杯、多姆·拉泰尔（dum rathair），所有这一切，基本上都集中在1180年代到13世纪最初几十年这样一个大约50、60年的核心时期内涌现出来的。
And I think, therefore, that the origins of the Grail do not lie in the mists of prehistory or in human psychology. They lie in a very, very specific and massively tumultuous period of medieval Latin history. And that period, Dominic, is a period that we have already done various episodes on, namely the period of the Albigensian Crusade. It's the age of Innocent III, the great Pope. So this is the papacy, Latin Christendom at its militant peak. And so just to go through what is happening at this period and to link it to certainly some of the authors of these grail romances. As I said, you've got the Albigensian Crusade, this crusade against heretics in the south of France that is very, very bloody.
因此我认为，圣杯的起源既不在史前迷雾中，也不在于人类心理之中，而是存在于一个非常、非常特殊且极其动荡的中世纪拉丁历史时期。而那个时期，多米尼克，正是我们已经做过各种节目的那个时期，也就是阿尔比十字军东征的时期。那是英诺森三世（Innocent III）这位伟大教皇的时代。因此，这是教皇制、拉丁基督教世界处于其好战巅峰的时期。为了回顾这一时期正在发生的事情，并将其与这些圣杯传奇的某些作者联系起来。正如我所说，你有阿尔比十字军东征，这是一场针对法国南部异教徒的十字军东征，非常、非常血腥。
So the Cathars, as they're called. The Cathars, as they're called. The people who take the ideological lead in this are the Cistercians, so a kind of order of monks who are the shock troops in the war against these supposed heretics in the south of France. One of the sequels to Chrétien is a former poet, a former enthusiast for chivalry called Elinard. He becomes a Cistercian monk, and he actually goes the south of France and he preaches against the Albigensians. So that's the context for his romance. 1204, you have the sack of france and he preaches against the albigensians so that's the context for his romance yeah 1204 you have the sack of constantinople so um this terrible event when the
所以，也就是所谓的卡特里派（Cathars）。所以，也就是所谓的卡特里派。在意识形态上领导这场运动的是熙笃会（Cistercians），这是一种僧侣修会，他们是打击法国南部这些所谓异教徒战争中的突击队。克雷蒂安的续集作者之一是一位前诗人、曾经的热忱骑士，名叫埃利纳尔（Elinard）。他成为了一名熙笃会修士，并且他真的去了法国南部，发表了反对阿尔比派的布道。所以这就是他的传奇故事的背景。1204年，你经历了法国的洗劫——并且他发表了反对阿尔比派的布道，所以这就是他的传奇故事的背景，是的。1204年，君士坦丁堡遭到洗劫；所以……嗯，这个可怕的事件，当时……
capital of of the the roman empire in the east is is destroyed by the crusaders and robert de boro who we mentioned in the first half he's the guy who comes up with the idea of of the grail being the um the cup of christ grail being the cup of Christ. He was in the service of a Lord who actually took part in the sack. You have the Reconquista in Spain going on. And according to Wolfram von Eschenbach, who wrote Parsifal, he says that he got the story from a guy who found it written in Arabic in Toledo, which is the kind of the great city where people are finding manuscripts of Aristotle and so on written in Arabic and translating it.
东方罗马帝国的首都……被十字军摧毁了。我们在前半集提到过的罗伯特·德·博龙（Robert de Boron），就是那个提出圣杯是……基督之杯的人。圣杯是基督之杯。他曾效力于一位实际参与了那次洗劫的领主。西班牙正在进行收复失地运动。根据撰写《帕西法尔》的沃尔夫冈·冯·埃森巴赫（Wolfram von Eschenbach）的说法，他说他是从一个在托莱多（Toledo）用阿拉伯语写成的手稿中发现这个故事的，托莱多那个伟大的城市里，人们正在寻找用阿拉伯语写成的亚里士多德等人的手稿并将其翻译过来。
So presumably he doesn't really. He says that because it makes it seem exotic and exciting and glamorous and dangerous and so on. So in other words, the Grail romances are, I think, patently influenced by what is going on in the broader world. Basically, what you have is a period where a long, drawn-out, century-and-a-half process of revolution is coming to its climax. This is a revolution that began back in the 11th century when radicals seized control of the commanding heights of the Roman church. And they embark on this great project to separate out the dimension of the church, the dimension of the holy from what they call the dimension of the cyclone, the dimension of the mortal, the dimension of things that are born
所以推测他其实并没有。他说那些话只是为了让故事显得异国情调、激动人心、充满魅力和危险等等。换句话说，我认为圣杯传奇显然受到了当时广阔世界上正在发生的事情的影响。基本上，你所面对的是这样一个时期：一场长达一个半世纪的漫长革命进程正走向高潮。这场革命始于11世纪，当时激进分子夺取了罗马教会的最高指挥权。他们着手开展这项伟大的工程，将教会的维度、神圣的维度与他们所谓的世界的维度、凡人的维度、那些生老病死的事物的维度——也就是我们后来称之为世俗的维度——区分开来。教会将自身定义为凌驾于这一切之上。它已经与世俗离婚了。所以这是一个神职人员必须发誓守贞的时期。他们之所以必须发誓守贞，是因为这使他们能够主持那项伟大的奥秘——罗马教会声称自己掌握着通往天堂钥匙的核心权利，也就是圣餐礼的仪式。
and die that we come to call the secular. And the church defines itself as being over and above this. It has divorced itself from that. So this is the period when priests, for instance, have to commit themselves to celibacy. And the reason they have to commit themselves to celibacy is that this enables them to preside over the great mystery that lies at the heart of the claim of the Roman church to hold the keys to heaven, which is the ritual of the Eucharist so this is taking taking mass basically taking the mass and the claim is that taking the the host the wafer the bread that this is literally the body of christ and that drinking the wine from the chalice from the cup this is literally the blood of christ thanks to a process called transubstantiation and this is kind of key to the
所以这基本上就是领圣餐——举行弥撒，而其声称的是，领受圣饼、圣糯米饼、面包，这字面意思就是基督的身体；从圣杯中饮用葡萄酒，这字面意思就是基督的血，这归功于一个叫做“化体说”（transubstantiation）的过程。这可以说是教会主张其拥有至高神圣性的核心所在——一种如此敬畏、如此深邃的神圣性，以至于它赋予了教会凌驾于欧洲各种世俗国家之上的主权和至高无上地位的正当性。没错，正如我们在节目中讨论的那样，
claim that the church has to embody a holiness so awesome so profound that it it licenses them to establish the church as something sovereign and supreme over all the kind of various secular states of europe right and as we discussed in our episode all the various secular states of Europe. And as we discussed in our episode on the Albigensians, there are people who are not in the cutting edge centers of Latin Europe in this time, whether it's Rome, whether it's the great universities of Bologna and Paris and Oxford, but people out in the sticks, out in the provinces who really resent that. And the Albigensians are kind of emblematic of that. And this is why in exactly the period that the Grail romances are being written,
欧洲所有形形色色的世俗国家。正如我们在关于阿尔比派的节目中所讨论的那样，当时有这样一群人，他们并不身处那个时代拉丁欧洲的前沿中心（无论是罗马，还是博洛尼亚、巴黎和奥尔克斯的高等学府），而是身处偏远乡下、身处各省，他们对此深感怨恨。阿尔比派正是这种情绪的象征。这就是为什么在圣杯传奇被创作的同一时期，
the Albigensians are being targeted basically for kind of annihilation. So the church, if it's going to embark on these crusades, whether it's directed against heretics within the fabric of Christendom, whether it's the Muslims in Spain, whether it's schismatic Christians in Constantinople. They can't do this on their own. They need warriors. They need soldiers to do it for them. And this is where knights come in. Because the paradox is that even as the church is claiming to have emancipated itself from the earthly demands, the earthly
阿尔比派基本上成了被赶尽杀绝的目标。因此，教会若要发起这些十字军东征——无论是针对基督教内部的异教徒、西班牙的穆斯林，还是君士坦丁堡的分离派基督徒。它们无法单枪匹马完成。它们需要武士。它们需要士兵来替它们完成这一切。这就是骑士登场的原因。因为这里的悖论在于，即便教会宣称自己已经从世俗的需求中解放出来，从堕落人类的世俗……
compromises of fallen humanity, it still needs warriors to defend it. Therefore, the question in what way can being a warrior, being a knight, being a chevalier, someone who rides around on a horse with swords and shields and lances, in what way can they be integrated into this kind of awesome vision of Christendom? So what they need is stories. They need an ideology that will reconcile the military and the religious, right? I think the ideology comes first because what you see in the two centuries that precede the emergence of the grail stories is a series of attempts on the part of the church to sacralize knighthood so the earliest of these is something called the peace of god where you have all these chevaliers all
妥协中解脱出来，它仍然需要武士来保卫它。因此，问题便在于：作为一个武士、一个骑士、一个“骑士老爷”（chevalier，即骑着马、带着剑、盾牌和长矛到处跑的人），他们将如何以某种方式融入基督教世界这种令人敬畏的宏大愿景之中呢？所以，他们需要故事。他们需要一种意识形态，能够将军事与宗教调和起来，对吧？我认为意识形态是先于故事出现的，因为你在圣杯故事出现前的两个世纪里看到的是：教会为使骑士制度神圣化所做的一系列尝试。其中最早的是所谓的“上帝的休战”（Peace of God），当时有那么多的骑士、
these knights who are busy attacking each other attacking monasteries attacking churches and the churches bring out holy relics from the from you know from their kind of inner sancta and the knights are so overwhelmed by the power of this that they kind of swear to hold the peace they kind of swear to the relics that are paraded through the streets or brought out into fields and this idea of the peace of god that the church can entrust knights with a kind of holy duty then becomes militarized with the idea of crusades which is born at the end of the the 11th century uh and these crusades kind of obviously roll out throughout the century that follows and are launched both against Constantinople and against
那些骑士整天忙着互相攻击、袭击修道院、攻击教堂，而教堂则从（你知道的）它们的核心禁地里拿出圣物，骑士们被这股力量震撼得目瞪口呆，于是他们发誓要维持和平，他们对着游行穿过街道或被带到田野里的圣物发誓。这种“上帝的休战”理念——即教会可以委托骑士承担某种神圣职责——随后伴随着十字军东征的理念而走向军事化。十字军东征诞生于11世纪末，这些十字军东征显然在随后的一个世纪里不断展开，并同时对君士坦丁堡、
the Muslims and against the Albigensians. But you also have this emergent idea that comes to be known as chivalry, this idea that a knight should properly follow Christian mission. So that's the bit, you know, the hermit who talks to Percival saying, you must look after young girls, after women, after orphans, after widows, and so on. That's where that is coming on. And that feeds into the romances that Chrétien tells. And this, again, I think is why they are so massively influential, so popular, is that because these are being written in French, therefore they are appealing not to clerics, not to scholars, but to the kind of people who would gather in a knight's hall.
穆斯林以及阿尔比派发起进攻。但你同时也拥有了这种被称为“骑士精神”的新兴理念——即骑士应该妥善遵循基督教使命的理念。这就是那部分，你知道的，与帕西法尔交谈的隐士所说的：你必须照顾年轻女孩、妇女、孤儿、寡妇等等。这就是它的来源。而这又滋养了克雷蒂安讲述的传奇故事。这也是为什么我认为它们具有如此巨大的影响力、如此受欢迎的又一个原因：因为这些故事是用法语写的，所以它们吸引的不是神职人员、不是学者，而是那些会聚集在骑士大厅里的那类人。
And the tensions, the complexities, the ambiguities that hedge figures like Lancelot and Gawain and indeed Percival around, these are stories that directly appeal to knights who are trying to think i want to be a brave knight i want to fight but i want to be a good christian as well yeah what does it mean to be a christian knight so why therefore why then the grayer why the the spear with the blood why the fisher king why why all those details why those details specifically right so it is only the priests who can approach the Eucharist. This is their awesome power. This is why they have sworn themselves to celibacy. Knights can't do that. But what Chrétien does in a very, very bold maneuver is to construct
而围绕着兰斯洛特、高文乃至帕西法尔等人物的种种张力、复杂性和暧昧性，正是那些试图思考“我想成为一名勇敢的骑士，我想战斗，但我也想成为一个好基督徒”的骑士们所能直接产生共鸣的故事。是的，成为一名基督教骑士意味着什么？那么，为什么呢？——为什么要讲圣杯？为什么要讲带血的长矛？为什么要讲渔夫国王？为什么要讲所有这些细节？为什么偏偏是这些细节呢？没错，因为只有神职人员才能接近圣餐。这是他们令人敬畏的力量。这就是为什么他们发誓守贞。骑士做不到这一点。但克雷蒂安通过一个非常、非常大胆的策略，构建了……
a kind of a myth in which knights are shown doing exactly that. Percival goes to the castle of the grail, and he beholds the spear, and he beholds the cup. And we're not told in Cretien's account that this is the spear that pierced the side of Christ, or that the grail is the cup that gathered the blood of Christ. But it's pretty evident from the speed with which people come to understand that that's what it is, that that probably was his intention, that that probably was the plot twist that he was building up to. And so aside from von Eschenbach's Parsifal, in which it's a stone, pretty much all the other Grail accounts are absolutely making play with these symbols of the passion, the grail, the spear dripping with blood. And in these romances, the Fisher King is able to stay alive despite his wound for decades,
这样一个神话：在其中，骑士们被描绘成正在做着同样的事情。帕西法尔来到了圣杯城堡，他看到了长矛，也看到了圣杯。克雷蒂安的叙述中并没有告诉我们这就是刺穿基督肋部的长矛，也没有说圣杯是收集基督鲜血的杯子。但从人们迅速理解这正是其所指的速度来看，这很可能就是他的意图，这很可能就是他一直在铺垫的情节转折。因此，除了冯·埃森巴赫的《帕西法尔》（其中圣杯是一块石头）之外，几乎所有其他关于圣杯的叙事都在大肆渲染这些受难的象征——圣杯、滴血的长矛。在这些传奇中，渔夫国王尽管受了伤，却能够依靠领受圣饼维持生命，达数十年、
centuries, millennia, because he is consuming a host. This is what keeps him alive, the body of Christ. And similar miracles are reported in this period. So there's a girl who's supposed to have lived for 40 years on nothing but the host, which is said to have been brought to her by a dove every Friday and then given to her by a priest every Sunday. There's a woman who lives only on the host that she gets at communion for 30 years. So this is an idea that is simultaneously pretty heretical, the idea that knights can approach the body and blood of Christ without priests to mediate it. But it's also very orthodox because it's upholding the mystery that lies at the heart of the claims of the Latin church to its supremacy. And this is basically one of the things that
数百年甚至数千年。正是基督的身体让他得以存活。那个时期也报道了类似的奇迹。比如有个女孩据说靠着圣饼活了40年，据说每个星期五都有一只鸽子给她送来圣饼，然后每个星期天由神职人员交给她。还有一个女人靠着领圣餐时得到的圣饼活了30年。所以这是一个兼具异端色彩的观念——即骑士无需神职人员从中斡旋就能接近基督的身体和宝血。但它同时也非常正统，因为它维护了拉丁教会宣称其至高无上地位的核心奥秘。而这基本上也是……
the Albigensians are being targeted against. This is the idea at the heart of Christianity, isn't it? That you have the body and blood of Christ and you will get eternal life. In essence, that's what the Christian promise is. Yeah, but the idea that it is literally the body and blood of Christ is something that's been kind of building up over several centuries, but it gets weaponized in this kind of particularly revolutionary period of the 11th century through the 12th century into the early 13th century. So the period that culminates in all these various crusades and in the Grail stories kind of emerging. So I think essentially that is what is going on, that the Grail romances,
阿尔比派被针对的靶子。这正是基督教核心的观念，不是吗？你拥有基督的身体和宝血，你就能获得永生。本质上，这就是基督教的承诺。是的，但“它字面意思就是基督的身体和宝血”这种观念，在几个世纪里一直在不断演变，但在11世纪、12世纪到13世纪初这个特别具有革命性的时期里，它被武器化了。所以，那个以所有这些形形色色的十字军东征以及圣杯故事的涌现为高潮的时期。因此我认为，本质上这就是正在发生的事情——圣杯传奇，
they're dangerous. They are kind of faintly treading on the toes of the clerical establishment. And that I think is why basically the church never mentions them. I mean, it preserves a very frosty silence about them. But at the same time, it tolerates them because they recognize that it is embodying a kind of very militant understanding of transubstantiation, of this idea that the body and the blood of Christ is incredibly dispensed by the priests is indeed the mystery of mysteries. The kind of the profoundest thing that you could possibly have. And it's that that gives the grail its sense of holiness. And it's that that underpins the whole plot of the last crusade. Famously, the knight who guards the grail in the
它们是危险的。它们在某种程度上有点踩到了神职人员建制派的脚趾头。我想这就是为什么教会基本上从不提及它们的原因。我的意思是，它对它们保持着一种非常冷冰冰的沉默。但与此同时，它又容忍了它们，因为它认识到，这些传奇体现了一种对“化体说”非常崇尚好战的理解——即基督的身体和宝血由神职人员无与伦比地分发，这确实是奥秘中的奥秘。这是你可能拥有的最深刻的事情。正是这一点赋予了圣杯神圣感。也正是这一点支撑了《圣杯奇兵》的整个情节。众所周知，在《圣杯奇兵》中守卫圣杯的那个骑士——
last crusade, you have to choose which grail do you drink from? Which cup do you go for? Someone chooses poorly, someone chooses wisely. And basically, to revert back to early 13th century terms, from the perspective of the establishment of the Latin church, the Albigensians, the Saracens, the schismatic Christians in Constantinople are choosing poorly. The devout, those who follow the teachings of the Latin church, are choosing wisely. And in that sense, the Grail Knights are choosing wisely. From the church's point of view, even if this does verge on heresy, surely the point is that basically the Grail story is an excellent recruiting tool.
你必须选择从哪个圣杯中饮水？你该选哪个杯子？有人选错了，有人选对了。基本上，回归到13世纪初的语境来看，从拉丁教会建制派的角度来看，阿尔比派、萨拉森人、君士坦丁堡的分离派基督徒都选错了。而虔诚者、那些遵循拉丁教会教义的人则选对了。从这个意义上说，圣杯骑士们选对了。从教会的角度来看，即使这有些接近异端，但关键在于圣杯故事是一个极佳的招募工具。
So all of these chivalric romances are fantastic in recruiting people to be knights, to fight for Christendom, to fight for in the name of the papacy, all of that sort of stuff. That's what they're after, right? Yeah. And so I think that that's why Galahad gets introduced and replaces Percival. Because to begin with, and this is why Percival has been so influential, not just in the Middle Ages, but right the way through the 19th, 20th, and 21st centuries, it does have the quality of a dream. You see the action through the eyes of Percival, these strange, haunting images. I mean, they're so powerful. They live so vividly in the imagination. But with the introduction of Galahad, it becomes much more kind of programmatic. So Galahad is a mountain that is name-checked in the Song of Songs, very important to the Cistercians, these monks who
因此，所有这些骑士传奇在招募人们成为骑士、为基督教世界而战、以教皇的名义去战斗等方面都是绝佳的，诸如此类。这正是他们所追求的，对吧？是的。所以我想这就是为什么加拉哈德（Galahad）被引入并取代了帕西法尔。因为一开始——这也是为什么帕西法尔不仅在中世纪，而且一直贯穿19世纪、20世纪和21世纪都具有如此巨大影响力——它的确带有一种梦幻般的特质。你透过帕西法尔的眼睛看待这些行动，那些奇异、挥之不去的意象。我的意思是，它们太强大了。它们如此生动地活在想象之中。但随着加拉哈德的引入，它变得更加程序化了。加拉哈德是《雅歌》中点名的一座山，对熙笃会（这些在打击异教战争中带头的僧侣）非常重要。他们说加拉哈德这座山是教会之首。因此，加拉哈德扮演了一种非常自觉的、几乎是寓言式的角色，我认为这反而让这些故事影响力降低了、实际上效率也变低了。
were taking the lead in the war against heresy. And they say that this mountain, Galahad, is the head of the church. So there's a kind of very self-conscious, kind of almost allegorical role that is being played by Galahad that I think makes those stories less influential, less effective, actually. Well, they're less strange, aren't they? Although there is a kind of strangeness in the climax of Galahad's vision of the Grail when he attains it, because basically what Galahad has is what Dante also gets in the Divine Comedy, which is what's called the beatific vision, the vision of the beatus, the happiness, the joy that the Christian soul after death has when beholding the face of God. You're not supposed to get it in this life, but Galahad does get it. And what's amazing is the description of how this beatific vision is
嗯，它们没那么诡异了，对吧？尽管在加拉哈德赢得圣杯并获得对圣杯的愿景的高潮部分，确实有一种诡异感，因为基本上加拉哈德所得到的，也就是但丁在《神曲》中所得到的——被称为“荣福直观”（the beatific vision），即看见“至福”（the beatus）的愿景，也就是基督灵魂在死后凝视上帝面容时所感到的幸福和喜悦。你本不应该在今生看到这个，但加拉哈德确实看到了。而令人惊奇的是，传奇中对这种荣福直观是如何构建的描述。这摘自《圣杯寻求记》（Quest of the Holy Grail），它描述了加拉哈德赢得圣杯的过程。加拉哈德在经历了荣福直观、圣杯的显现、上帝的面容时说道：“此时我坦然目睹了言语无法描述、心灵无法构想的事物。在此我看到了伟大勇气的开端和英勇行为的根本原因。在此我看到了所有奇迹中的奇迹。”
framed in the romance. So this is from the Quest of the Holy Grail, which kind of describes Galahad's winning of the Grail. And Galahad, as he has the beatific vision, the revelation of the Grail, the face of God, for now I see openly what tongue cannot describe nor heart conceive. Here I see the beginning of great daring and the prime cause of prowess. Here I see the marvel of all other marvels. And it's being couched in knightly terms. These are not terms that Thomas Aquinas or other great theologians would go for. He's describing it as being brilliant. The beatific vision is all about being a great knight, going on adventures, going on quests. But you can see why I think this is a problem for Protestants. So you said that
而这一切都是用骑士的术语表达出来的。这些都不是托马斯·阿奎那或其他伟大神学家会使用的术语。他将其描述为一种辉煌。荣福直观完全关乎成为一个伟大的骑士、去经历冒险、去进行寻找。但你可以理解为什么我认为这对新教徒来说是个问题。所以你刚才说……
people have been continuously fascinated for the Grail. Actually, they haven't been. The moment the Reformation comes, interest in the Grail kind of stops. Because it's seen as superstitious? Absolutely. Transubstantiation. I mean, the idea of whether the wine and the bread at communion are literally the blood and the body of Christ is fundamental to the Reformation. Protestants say it isn't. And so I think that they kind of instinctively recognize that the Grail rituals, the Grail romances are very much a product of the Catholic Middle Ages. And that's why they kind of drop it like a hot plate. But I think it also explains why
人们一直对圣杯着迷。事实上，并没有。一旦宗教改革到来，对圣杯的兴趣基本上就停止了。因为这被视为迷信？绝对是的。化体说。我的意思是，圣餐中的酒和面包字面意思上是否就是基督的血和身体，这是宗教改革的核心。新教徒说不是。所以我认为他们凭直觉认识到，圣杯的仪式、圣杯的传奇很大程度上是天主教中世纪的产物。这就是为什么他们像扔烫手山芋一样把它们扔掉。但我也认为这解释了为什么……
when the Grail romances get rediscovered in the 19th century and into the 20th century, there's a sense that you've got the hardware there, but the software has been erased. And so all the kind of theories, whether it's the Jungian theories, the idea that it's kind of secret bloodlines or that it's pagan myths that have been Christianized, this is an attempt to kind of rewrite software that can power the hardware, if that makes sense. Right. So yes, we like the story, but we've lost sight of actually the essence, the meaning.
当圣杯传奇在19世纪和20世纪被重新发现时，人们会有一种感觉：你拥有了硬件，但软件已经被删除了。所以所有各种各样的理论——无论是荣格理论、关于它是秘密血脉的观点，还是它是被基督教化的异教神话的观点——都只是一种试图重写能够驱动硬件的软件的尝试，如果这说得通的话。没错。所以，是的，我们喜欢这个故事，但我们已经忽视了它的本质和含义。
Yeah. We've got all these amazing images with these kind of adventures, but we can't quite get a handle on it. We want to know what the secret of the grail is. I mean, actually, the secret of the grail is there. It's written very, very obviously in the history of the late 12th and early 13th centuries but because we're not familiar with that anymore we look for for other secrets other ways of explaining it right yes okay that makes complete sense to me and also tom that explains why to my mind indiana jones the last
是的。我们拥有所有这些伴随着冒险的惊人意象，但我们无法真正掌握它的精髓。我们想知道圣杯的秘密是什么。我的意思是，事实上，圣杯的秘密就摆在那里。它非常、非常显眼地写在12世纪末和13世纪初的历史中，但由于我们对此不再熟悉，我们便去寻找其他的秘密、其他的解释方式。没错，是的。好吧，这对我来说完全说得通。而且，汤姆，这也解释了为什么在我看来，《夺宝奇兵3：圣杯奇兵》是原三部曲中最弱的一部，因为实际上圣杯只是一个纯粹的麦格芬（MacGuffin）。它没有那种……这是一个非常基督教的象征，这就是为什么它是我的最爱。不，不，不，不，它没有《约柜》那么强大，《约柜》真的很诡异，而且那部电影的结局——对于那些看过《夺宝奇兵1：法柜奇兵》、并且在孩童时期第一次看到它的人来说——是一个巨大的震撼，它确实充满了这种超自然的力量。当然，正如每个人都知道的那样，《魔宫传奇》是三部曲中最好的一部。话说回来，关于圣杯，汤姆，你完全没有提到的一点是——最后，当我们……接近尾声时，我们正走向仲夏……呃，夏末，格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury）。它不是格拉斯顿伯里，这个想法是从哪里来的？它不是格拉斯顿伯里，而且那从来都不是格拉斯顿伯里神话的一部分。格拉斯顿伯里的修道院院长们在非常晚的时候……
crusade is the weakest of the original trilogy because actually the grail is just a pure mcguffin it doesn't quite have that it's a very christian symbol which is why it's my favorite no no no no it's not as powerful as the ark of the covenant which is really weird and the ending of that film for those people who've seen raiders of the lost ark and when you first see it if you're a child comes as a great shock and it's really charged with this kind of supernatural power of course temple of doom as everybody knows is the best of the three films so on the grail tom one place you haven't mentioned at all finally just as we uh come to an end we're getting towards midsummer well late summer glastonbury it's not a glastonbury where does
从来都不是格拉斯顿伯里神话的一部分。格拉斯顿伯里的修道院院长们在15世纪非常晚的时候才开始这样说。就在马洛里（Malory）写完他的亚瑟王神话传说之后不久，他们才开始说圣杯被带到了格拉斯顿伯里，但这已经有点晚了，因为30年之后，修道院就被关闭了，在托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）的世界里，根本没有神圣荆棘、超自然圣杯或任何此类东西的容身之所。好吧。好吧，听着，你算是把圣杯给彻底祛魅了，这其实挺遗憾的。我不认为我是在祛魅。我是把它置于……
that idea come from it's not a glastonbury and that's never really part of of the glastonbury myth the um the abbots of glastonbury do very late never really part of the Glastonbury myth. The abbots of Glastonbury do very late in the 15th century. So just after Mallory has written his accounts of the Arthurian myths, they do start saying that the Holy Grail was brought to Glastonbury, but it's a bit late because 30 years later, the Abbey gets closed down and there's no place in Thomas Cromwell's world for holy thorns and supernatural chalices or any of that stuff. All right. Well, listen, so you've rather debunked the Holy Grail, which is kind of a shame. I don't think I have debunked it. I've placed it in the context of
中世纪基督教世界核心的伟大奥秘的语境中。是的，但我想很多人都在寻找失落的血脉，不是吗？还有外星人和亚特兰蒂斯之类的事物。真遗憾。抱歉。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，这真的、真的很吸引人。你启发了我，让我想要回去听瓦格纳（Wagner）的《帕西法尔》，这对我家里的其他人来说绝对是个可怕的前景。谁能想到两期关于《夺宝奇兵》的播客会以如此阳春白雪的调子收尾呢？带着这个调子，我们要说再见了。再见。感谢收听《剩下的都是历史》。若想收听加更节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
the great mystery that lay at the heart of medieval Christendom. Yeah, but I think a lot of people are looking for lost bloodlines, aren't they? And aliens and Atlantis and things. Tough. Sorry. All right. Well, on that bombshell, Tom, that was really, really fascinating. You've inspired me to go back and listen to Wagner's Parsifal, which is a terrifying prospect for the other members of my household. Who knew that two podcasts about Indiana Jones would end on such a highbrow note? And on that note, we will say goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。那是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。网址是 restishistertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。